AND HERES WIDE.
AND THIS ONE SLIDES UNDERNEATH
THE ARM OF CAMPBELL. ZACHA WITH
HIS ELEL CENTRE ICE. IN THE NEWR
REBOUND.
SCORES.
AND BOQVIST HAS ANOTHER.
AND NEW JERSEY HAS A 2-NOTHTH
AN EXCELLENT PLAY WITH GOOD
COMPOSURE IN FRONT OF THE NET AS
BOQVIST MAKES IT AHE TURNED THE
FIRST GOAL.
NOW FIVE GOALS BACK FOR THE
RICHARD OMES HUGHES.
FANCY MOVE AND A
ON THE FACE OF SHELDON KEEFE
HERE.
THIS STARTS I
THIS WAS GOING TO BE A AND
MAKES THE STOP OFF
TIPPED IN FRONT.
NUMBER 34 HAS RIGHT
INTO HIS CREST.
INSTEAD MATTHEWS GETS A PIECE OF
AND TWO MORE STOPS INJERSEY.
AND JESPER BOQVIST OVER THE
LINE.
BOQVIST JUST PUTS GOES.
NYLANDER BATTLES THERE WITH
SIEGENTHALER.
THAT PASS KNOCKED DOWN AS
KERFOOT
HOW ABOUT THIS COMPOSURE HERE BY
JASON SPEZZA.
YOU SEE HOW HE SLID OUT T
YOU KNOW NOW YOU HAVE GOT A TEA.
NOW ALONG THE BOARDS.
AND THAT
MATTHEWS IN FRONT.
SCORES!
MITCH MARNER'S TIEDONE.
SHELDON KEEFE TALKED TODAY ABOUT
NOT ALWAYS WINNING THE DRAW WHAT
.
BRATT GAVE IT BACK.
NOW A PASS ACROSS BWAIT.
PULLED BACK,INE: MATTHEWS CAME
DEEP DEFENSIVELY AS THE
GOALTENDER ON TH